the preparation had been tough but Greta
Thornburg is now undertaking the journey
of a lifetime at the southern English
port of Plymouth the racing yacht the
militia - a professional crew and her
father awaiting them or the challenges
of the Atlantic Ocean for at least the
next two weeks despite all the
technology designed to make this a
carbon-neutral journey there is little
luxury and even less privacy this
teenager who has become a beacon for so
many young climate crisis activists now
prepared to brave the challenges of the
open ocean in the hope that her message
will be heard and understood great
earthen Berg's trip across the Atlantic
is expected to take two weeks she aims
to be in New York for the next month's
UN climate action summit but the
crossing won't be easy
August is peak hurricane season after
New York
Thornburg says she'll travel by train
and bus to Canada and Mexico she also
plans to attend the annual UN climate
conference in Santiago Chile in December
and hood Berg is doing this despite the
criticism and vitriol she has
experienced from climate change deniers
I'm not concerned about reactions what
I'm concerned about is whether we we
will do something or not whether the
people in power will react and act with
necessary force it's taken the
determination of one sixteen-year-old
schoolgirl to spark off a global
movement where great ofin burke has been
urging politicians but do something more
than say the right words but to put it
into action as well all over the world
ton Berg's message of taking action has
resonated with young people like
Scarlett and Francis they're worried
that the older generations do not
understand the crisis the planet is
facing so adults have directed democracy
they can directly control the
composition if the leg
to get their prints across but we can't
do that and when Greta decided to strike
from school it was bold and something we
haven't seen before for example in the
UK the Parliament has declared to
climate emergency but this isn't legally
binding there's no action proposed to
reach the carbon neutral by 2050 target
which is already too late according to
the science the vessel will also be
collecting essential data such as
measuring the temperature of the ocean
to assess how much carbon is being
absorbed it is a journey fraught with
risk but with the effects of climate
change already being felt across the
globe it's one this teenager believes is
worth making
Sonia gai a go al jazeera plymouth
southern England